hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in a short
lecture existentialism is a humanism
jean-paul Sartre brings up three terms
which he calls grand eloquent anguish
forlorn nest and despair or in the
original French on gwass navei Simone
and days is for each of these is a vital
characteristic you could say of the
human condition Sartre is is not saying
that they're actually part of human
nature because of course from the
existentialist point of view as he
articulates it human nature is something
that we ourselves determine it existence
precedes essence but each of these you
could say is a dimension of the
inescapable human condition so there is
something that does apply to all
humanity and he provides an explanation
of what he means by each of these terms
in the course of the lecture as he
actually says as you will see it's all
quite simple so he's suggesting that
anybody can grasp these so he says let's
take English first the existentialist
at once say it all together that man or
the human being is a
and another way of translating anguish
is anxiety this is coming from the onth
that is referenced by Heidegger anguish
anxiety these sort of things overlap
with each other to some degree in
English and why do we feel or why are we
you could say shot through with anxiety
so that it's really at the core of who
we are it has to do with the fact that
we cannot evade the responsibility of
self determinative choice that is choice
where we decide not only what we're
going to do but why we're going to do it
and what we're not going to do and you
know what our priorities are and what
kind of person we are that's how we make
use of ourselves so Sartre says that the
person who involves themself and who
realizes that they're not only the
person they choose to be but also a
lawmaker in effect who is at the same
time choosing all human humankind as
well as themself and we'll come back to
that in just a moment cannot escape the
feeling of the total and deep
responsibility why I start talking about
making decisions not just for oneself
but for everybody else that's part of
the nature of human decision we are
affirming like it or not our stance as
the stance that not only we should take
but any reasonable person or everybody
should take and start acknowledges that
there's plenty of people who are like
I'm not expecting everybody else to act
like that as a matter of fact I hope
that they don't you know like when
they're stealing something you know the
thief doesn't want to be stolen from you
can stay there's a sort of performative
or inherent contradiction there but
according to start within the core of
that person's being there is this
anxiety that leads them to have to
repress it and ignore the fact that they
could have chosen otherwise
and that they could be choosing
something that's that's that's better he
said there's no escaping this disturbing
thought except by a kind of
double-dealing a person who lies and
makes excuses for themselves by saying
not everybody does that is someone with
an uneasy conscience because the act of
lying implies that a universal value is
conferred upon the line so we're always
in anxiety we always have to make
decisions even if we choose not to make
a decision we're still making a decision
you can't get away from that until
you're dead that's that's the the basis
of human being is decision choosing
oftentimes without knowing the full
situation that you're choosing in right
so we either feel that anxiety or we can
steal it from ourselves we repress it we
bury it within he says anguish is
evident even when it does conceal itself
and he brings up the example of Abraham
he also talks about this woman who is
hearing hallucination someone would
speak to her on the telephone and give
her orders her doctor asked who is it
talk who's talking to you and she said
well it's God and then what proof that
SART says do I have that it is God if an
angel comes to me what proof is it that
it's an angel if I hear voices what
proof is there that they come from
heaven and not from Heller from the
subconscious or a pathological condition
I'm the one who chooses that
interpretation and I am responsible for
that choice so I can't get away from
that I can't get away from the anxiety
of having to choose over and over and
over again even if I make a commitment I
say okay I'm gonna make this choice once
and for all
I still have to keep making that
commitment or rather remaking that
commitment reach using every time that
there's a possibility for me to go
somewhere else with it
so we can't evade choices and the
choices that we make are with
indeterminate circumstances we don't
entirely determine the very condition
for our choosing he has the example
here a military leader who takes the
responsibility for an attack and sends a
certain number of men to their death he
chooses to do so and he alone makes the
choice for the most part orders come
from above but the orders are always too
broad he has to interpret them and he
says in making a decision he cannot help
feeling a certain anguish all leaders
know this anguish this does not keep
them from acting on the contrary it's
the very condition of their acting a lot
of people want to say well I'm not going
to make a decision until everything is
perfectly clear no you actually do have
to make a decision and you have to bear
the responsibility for it the next thing
that he talks about is forlorn Ness do
they sum all and what he means by this
is he formulates it in in one quick way
of expressing it there is no a priori
good when it comes to our
decision-making there is nothing that is
out there in the world or coming down to
us from on high or within ourselves
speaking you know with the still voice
of conscience or anything like that that
gives us an automatic here's your answer
there's nothing like that and the only
reason according to start why we think
that there is is because we convinced
ourselves of that we use our freedom to
tell ourselves that there's this thing
conditioning our freedom he frames it in
terms of we mean that God does not exist
and we have to face all the consequences
on this why bring up God well if God did
exist and gods
you know statements were clear of course
for many religious people the fact that
God exists does not clear up everything
and actually complicates things but
let's go with start on this if God did
exist then there would be some sort of
hierarchy of values or imperatives or
whatever it happens to be that we could
rely upon completely and follow out and
human beings would have a determinant
nature because they would be created by
God with that very nature
and we could examine it and figure it
out so you know this is a rejection of
not only divine command theories but
also natural law theories and many other
ethical theories as well so he's
rejecting religious ethics any sort of
ethics that would base itself upon God
said or God did or any anything
referencing God he's also rejecting a
lot of secular ethics and he talks about
a certain kind of secular ethics popular
in France in the 1800s also back in the
1700s to some extent among the
Enlightenment Phil assaults but
especially in the 1800's and going down
to starts own time that says that God is
a useless and costly hypothesis we're
going to discard it but in order for
there to be an ethics the society of
civilization it's essential certain
values be taken seriously and that they
be considered as having an OP priori
existence it must be obligatory a priori
that is before any experience the you
know sort of a universal condition for
humankind to be honest not to lie - not
to beat your wife to have children etc
etc and you know what what Sartre sees
this is doing is basically trying to
have your God cake have your not god
cake and eat it too right you're trying
to get the same sort of thing out
philosophy or science or some other
scheme that religious people got out of
it and start says no no we have to take
it seriously if there is no God then as
Dostoevsky says everything is permitted
we have to acknowledge that there's this
wide range of possibility and
variability and we don't get any sort of
criteria that we can rely upon as an
absolute starting point for ethics so he
says there's no fixed and given human
nature
that we could rely upon we can't look
within and as natural law theorists say
use reason to examine our impulses we
can't or you know inclinations so that
we can figure out well
life is to be protected we have to
educate our children we should learn the
truth no we those may be true but we
have to make them true we have to choose
them we can't just say oh well I've got
the answers now I need just to apply it
so no fixed and given human nature start
also said there is no determinism and
here this could easily be misunderstood
he doesn't mean that if I drop this book
it won't fall to the earth you know not
just nine times out of ten but
guaranteed or all the other things that
we think are deterministic but the human
being is constantly emerging out of the
term causal deterministic Nexus and then
you know using the their freedom and
coming back into it with the Nexus being
changed as a result so we can't claim
any sort of determinism whether it be an
individual one of well I've got the
genes that caused me to be this way or
my environment made me this way
we can't talk about it in terms of
larger social determinisms well I was
born into poverty so I had to behave
this way or I was born into you know the
house with the proverbial silver spoon
in my mouth as a rich person so I have
to see things this way start says no
those are cop-outs
we always do choose there is no
determinism that decides for us how
we're going to choose we choose to make
that determinism deterministic in our
choices we are the ones who say oh well
you know Freud says that I have this
complex or the CBT therapist says I have
to look at things this way or pick
whatever other psychological or
sociological or whatever other theory
you want were the ones who take that on
and decide to act that way he criticizes
as well the appeal to passion he says
the existentialist does not believe in
the power of passion he will never agree
that a sweeping passion is a ravaging
torrent which fatally leads a man to
certain acts and as therefore is an
excuse he thinks that the human being is
responsible for their passion so whether
that passion be that of revenge or that
of love that of
Saro that of anxiety it's what we do
with our emotions that decides our
actions not the emotions sweeping us
along and making us follow in their
course he says that sort of romanticism
or that sort of fatalism
is something that we choose it's not
something that we can take is an opera
re he also says there's no signs that we
could appeal to you know like a sign
from God or the universe or pick
whatever you want karma and some vague
you know new agey sense we are the ones
who choose to see them as signs we are
the ones to interpret them as signs
there's no getting away for that that is
why we are forlorn we don't have
anything that solves the question of
life and the questions of choices and
actions for us we have to choose so you
can see how for laurynas and anguish go
along together
the third condition that start talks
about is another condition for our
choices and actions and that is what he
calls despaired and it's a little bit
miss named right this sends a very
pessimistic message because of its
connotations both in the French days as
far and in the English despair but all
he means by despair is that we ourselves
are the ones who have to provide
everything we can count on the world to
some extent he talks about probabilities
he says we have to confine ourselves to
reckoning only with what depends on our
will or on the ensemble of probabilities
which make our action possible what do
we actually have any say in I won't even
say control over but say in what we
choose and then this penumbra of
possibilities that surround us they may
cooperate with us they may totally
overturn us so the existentialist can
say for example
you're out in the middle of the ocean
the boat goes down you manage to get
into one of the lifeboats and now the
lifeboat you know you're close to shore
but it's a pretty rough sea you know and
you're like well I think I better start
swimming right rather than just simply
cling to the lifeboat you choose to get
out there the waves may not cooperate
with you
you may die there's nothing that says oh
well if you just put it out there into
the universe the universe will respond
to you know the universe may crush you
down right or it could be other human
beings who are not going to cooperate
with you a great example of this is in
starts famous short story the wall you
know nobody there
is really able except for the narrating
character to evade their execution
because other people want to execute
them and the only thing that saves him
is a stroke of luck
all we can count on is ourselves and
then perhaps some cooperation from the
rest of the world as he says when we
want something he says we have to reckon
with probabilities
I may be counting for example on the
arrival of a friend the friend is coming
by rail or streetcar this supposes how
many different things the train arrives
on schedule the streetcar will not jump
the track the moment the possibilities I
am considering are not rigorously
involved by my action I ought to says
disengage myself from them because no
God no scheme can adapt the world and
its possibilities to my will then he
considers a response from one of the
main movements of the time the Marxist
who say well if you're doing the right
thing you can count on the workers the
proletariat to see your project further
and start says no you can't why not
because they are also free human beings
like myself they could choose next week
to all become fascist
that's the example that he uses you
can't count on a movement you can't
count on some sort of program you can't
count on anything to necessarily see
your action through and so does that
keep
from acting no of course not you still
have to act but you do it in despair
knowing that your action may be totally
ineffective knowing that other people
may misinterpret it because that is the
possibility for their choices so we have
these three fundamental dimensions or
characteristics of the human condition
being narrated here you see how all
three of them fit into each other
anguish for lorna and spare
you